all right I meant to get this earlier in
the week didn't have time but it is very
interesting over the weekend Donald
Trump spoke to a sycophant crowd in Fort
Myers Florida this was the Lee County
Republican party event and it was
completely Bonkers now maybe the one
moment
where we questioned whether the crowd
was as sycophantic as we believed them
to be was when Trump in uh insulted I
guess we would say or went after Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis there was muted
Applause at this moment but Trump
pulling out the standard grievances
about DeSantis during this this event
and again it's a Florida Republican
crowd friendlier to DeSantis and there
was only a smattering of Applause I got
1.2 million more votes than your
successful Governor's campaign you know
that we got 1.2 million
sure I'd love to have your support sir
I'd love to have your support I'm down
at about three I'd love to have you
support sir just think about it then
there was like a rocket ship after I
gave it otherwise right now you'd have a
lawyer someplace looking for business
if that
there you go now of course it's not
really the truth as you might expect
we've looked at the polling uh track
record for desantis's uh election and
um in fact
it was months after Trump's endorsement
that DeSantis started gaining in the
polls so it wasn't exactly the explosive
rocket ship that Trump wants you to
believe it to be
extraordinarily disturbingly Donald
Trump said that he would appoint if he
became president and had the opportunity
he would appoint more Supreme Court
Justices like Clarence Thomas he says
Clarence Thomas is under siege for for
no good reason of course it's very scary
to think that you look at the Supreme
Court and you say oh we need more people
like Clarence Thomas
thank you
I will appoint Rock Solid
constitutional concern
in the mold of Justice Antonin Scalia
and the great
Justice Clarence Thomas who is under
siege right now right
he's under siege right now
for doing nothing
he is really they're going after him
right now he's right about Thomas is
doing nothing he hasn't spoken on the
court for how long
everybody else talked about appointing
conservatives to court I am the only one
who actually did it I appointed almost
federal judges all told it was
pretty substantially more than that a
record and three great Supreme Court
Justices so that was a big that was a
big thing
that was big so of course horrifying to
hear as we learned that Clarence Thomas
is likely the most corrupt and unethical
Supreme Court Justice in a hundred years
that Trump says we need more people like
Clarence Thomas and this is of course
the weaponized contrarianism
contrarianism for the sake of
contrarianism that has become a Hallmark
of the modern Maga movement Donald Trump
also doing this routine where he says he
will try to get DA's and Attorneys
General fired based on essentially their
political orientation
[Applause]
stop the local Marxist prosecutors who
released rapists and murderers while
persecuting conservatives on day one of
my new Administration I will direct the
doj to investigate every radical D.A and
attorney general in America for their
radical according to whom illegal racist
and reverse enforcement of the law
a genuinely deranged and dangerous idea
and understand that Trump wants if Trump
had his way
he would get rid of any federal
government employee that simply didn't
vote for him even if they are
non-political Trump that this is one of
Trump's big big Crusades he wants to be
able to fire everyone and replace them
with loyalists even in bureaucratic
positions where politics really
shouldn't make a difference and he wants
to do the same thing with DA's and
Attorneys General not going to happen by
the way just completely absurd but it's
not going to happen Trump also going
after his own former Attorney General
William Barr criticizing him if Bill
Barr had any courage instead of worrying
about being impeached by the Democrats
these people would have all been taken
care of but we have to do it a different
way if he had courage we need people
with courage he had no courage he didn't
want to be impeached sir I don't want to
be impeached
I said what's wrong with being impeached
I got impeached twice and my numbers
went up
he wasn't he wasn't a brave person
[Applause]
it wasn't a bad person
now he sits back and pontificates it's
all Trump do so Trump that the man
didn't have courage he didn't have
courage to go out and do what you had to
do with respect to the election yeah and
of course who hired him it was Trump
trump ran on I will hire the best people
and he ended up hiring some of the worst
people even by his own admission Trump's
delusions of grandeur certainly didn't
slow down at all claiming that when he
won in 2016 not only did he save the
country he says he also saved the
Republican Party good point
to put it simply on Election Day 2016 we
didn't just save America we saved the
Republican party we did
hard to believe really given the
shambles that the Republican Party finds
itself in today Trump continuing the
delusions by saying he's probably the
most honest person who has ever been
president even more honest than Honest
Abe there's no crime I got indicted for
no crime
they're all saying even the Democrats
well we don't see this as a crime if
there is no crime
you know a friend of mine said you're
probably the most honest person to ever
be prepared
and then capping off a completely insane
evening Donald Trump then stopping at a
pizza place and taking a bite out of a
slice and asking whether anyone wants
the slice that Trump took a bite out of
here
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course they cheer it is indeed a
cult many of them wanting a slice that
Donald Trump took a bite out of so this
is going to be the next year I hate to
inform people that that this is what
American politics will be like meanwhile
hopefully President Joe Biden will keep
accomplishing things and uh I think for
that we we should really encourage that
Donald Trump speaking this afternoon in
New Hampshire at what I'm certain will
be a very unhinged campaign event we
will cover it live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook
but do not be confused this is indeed a
cult
I love my car which is electric I love
my bicycle and I have to say that the
perfect medium in between is my electric
bike by Electric if you're looking to
spend about eight hundred dollars or so
on an e-bike electric is where you want
to go I've tried e-bikes that cost seven
thousand dollars electric delivers the
same performance and specs but at a much
more reasonable price point I take my
electric e-bike everywhere these days
I've almost completely ditched my
regular bike for now e-bikes are of
course better for the environment than
taking a car the e-bike gives you more
flexibility and range than a regular
bicycle you can go further you can see
more my e-bike is just my favorite form
of cardio at this point it comes fully
assembled to your door it includes a
bright LCD display seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist and a
powerful battery that's removable so you
can bring it indoors for charging it's
also fully foldable so I can put it in
the back of my car and they have
financing for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below